my name is James Keats I'm apparently
the only post human alive who's still
capable of having nightmares and I don't
know why hopes you in the short film
basically is the five minutes that would
be at the beginning of the posthuman
feature film at which we are hopefully
going to be filming one day basically it
starts with a day in the life of James
Keats who is my character it's some time
in the future and nanobots
have been invented basically they have
been implanted in everybody's bodies and
they give everybody special abilities
one you can fly you can breathe in outer
space based on having sort of a force
field around it there's so many cool
things on the nanobots do and one of the
very basic things that they do which
they have iPhone apps that do for you
now is they wake you up of a specific
time where you know that your REM sleep
has been perfect and then you wake up
with a a fantastic sleep good dreams but
it turns out that James Keats has
nightmares which is something that
nobody in the world has anymore based on
just this technology and he wakes up
from a nightmare like he has on many
more many other days next to his wife
Kathryn who chooses not to wake up with
him at the same time because she's not
very happy with him and there are there
are certain reasons that she's unhappy
with him he hasn't been unfaithful but
she thinks what he's done is almost
worse and I don't want to give too much
away because all we've done is the five
minute proof of concept and a I hope
that people watch the movie and I hope
also people choose to read the amazing
books which I've only recently come into
contact with when I became included in
the project and I I love the book so I
don't want to take that away from any of
the people watching the posthuman short
film is about the first 20 years no
pages of the posthuman novel so it takes
place in the future where our bodies are
enhanced by something called man so we
have really cool abilities like the
ability to fly the ability to put a
force field around ourselves and the
ability to connect
everybody on the web but you're
constantly connected so the downside of
that is that if some of your thoughts
for example if somebody has extremely
aroused by another person their partner
is alerted so that's the the issue
that's going on in this particular
section of post-humans so um
James Keith's was aroused by another
woman in his wife Catherine kids who I
play isn't very happy about getting that
notification so she's upset with him
they're having a very difficult time in
their marriage
this isn't Katherine's ball we're both
prisoners of the same situation
the same well she's a good woman I love
her
I never would have heard her and I think
on some level she knows that but what
can she do
we both live in a world that monitors us
from the inside out she she loves James
or they did love each other at some
point but because she was alerted that
he was aroused by someone else to the
point that he could have cheated on her
if she has a hard time loving him and
interacting with him
so she's just a she's a very heartbroken
woman um while I I saw an ad for the
project and it was very detailed and I
looked into the books a little and saw
how popular they were and thought it was
such an incredible opportunity that I
happened to come across and I send in my
pictures in my resume and then I met
with them with David and Jenny's who
made this film and it was like right
away they were they seemed really
passionate about me and really say about
me and we're talking about how excited
they were about Madison and I'm just
their passion alone and how they
described the character in the film made
me want to become a part of it
I'd say the thing that got me interested
in this project was David himself I met
David at a Starbucks out by by the
university here in Vancouver and
immediately he showed off how much of
this project meant to him it was it was
such a beautiful sort of moment of a man
explaining his vision and what he wanted
from from the movie that he wanted to
make he wanted to make it for his fans
he posthuman and David himself has
amazing fans out there that read his
books and what he wants is a
demonstration of what that can be in
film he wasn't able to find that he
wasn't able to find someone to make
exactly what he wanted and it was it was
almost difficult for him to to go about
releasing his baby because he knew it
wasn't gonna be exactly what he wanted
to be so then he decided to do it
himself
I've had a lot of success in my career
by boiling things down to their
fundamentals I'm a big believer in first
principles of like in physics and and I
think you can apply that to most
so whenever I'm dealing with a problem I
just boil things down to what are the
fundamentals of this and so with
filmmaking when you really think about
it that fundamentals are you know you
need a camera and you need a setting and
then you need actors to inhabit that
setting and that's really all you need
you don't even actually need a script
because the actors could improv
everything I recommend the script but
technically you don't need it you just
need to deal with those other
foundations and then anything else that
you bring is something that you bring
this tailor-made for your individual
project and so when you start to think
about it that way it seems a lot less
daunting so for me I had to knock down
before I did anything else those those
three foundations and so the first one
was camera so you know I'm a technology
person obviously you know writing
science fiction and I'm a big believer
in Moore's Law for sure I mean you don't
believe in Moore's Law it's just a fact
that information technology is doubling
in price performance every 12 to 18
months so that's pretty exciting
especially in this new era of digital
filmmaking but I had worked with a
couple of small production companies
here in Vancouver and they were looking
at using the the tools that professional
productions these days usually use for
digital filmmaking and you know so they
were looking into Reds and Ariel exes
and I was astounded by the price of the
technology and how cumbersome the
technology was as well and that you know
you you couldn't really own these
cameras they were so expensive that it
was cost prohibitive so you had to just
rent them and to me that seemed that it
would cause an issue when it came to
becoming proficient with the cameras and
then you end up needing a director of
photography and so I was interested in
whether or not I could actually own one
of the cameras and I started to look
into them to learn as much as I could
about them and you know I was looking at
comparisons between a lot of digital
film cameras that are really
professional grade and what I kept
seeing
in the comment sections of these you
know reviews and and comparisons was a
lot of people talking about this
Blackmagic camera which I'd never heard
of before
and he looked into it myself and saw
there was a huge difference in price I
mean it's laughable Blackmagic cameras
can be you know one-fiftieth or
one-hundredth in some cases the price of
these other cameras with similar size
sensors so you know I was very intrigued
by this because it seemed as though
there was one company that had already
it was like a company from the future
you know they they had already made this
technology affordable and it was
something that the the masses could get
their hands on but of course you wonder
is it too good to be true so my wife and
I actually started to do a lot of
research specifically on the different
models of Blackmagic cameras and we were
looking at Vimeo and we were looking at
Shane Hurlbutt is really good he's a
director of photography that looks into
all these different types of cameras and
and we saw that the camera was holding
up really well against the best cameras
out there so we had the potential of
actually you know buying a camera
outright especially for us we were very
interested in the Blackmagic pocket
Cinema Camera because it was less than
$1000 about the same as a rental fee for
one of these other cameras and I if I
can own it outright I could test it
I could become proficient with it myself
I could try out different lenses and
different filters and different
stabilizing equipment and that's exactly
what I did
we got the Blackmagic and you know after
watching lots of reviews for it and we
tried some different lenses and we did
some tests lucky for us there was
another lens that had just come on the
market another affordable really great
lens and this was the Sigma 18 and 35
millimeter lens this one did you know
the wider stuff just as well as the RO
Kinyon did but it didn't have that fish
I look on the close-up so we had the
we had the tools we needed at that point
the next thing we looked into with
stabilization we grabbed a glidecam
which was really important we used it a
lot we have a slider so when you look at
the proof-of-concept and you see those
gorgeous slider shots that's the result
of having that slider and I did have a
body mount that we used a little bit and
then also two tripods to both hold the
slider up and then also just for our
fixed camera position shots when we were
doing you know medium range close-ups
and we also had a meta bones smart lens
adapter that we put on the black magic
which is fantastic because that allowed
us to look let in a lot of light and it
made us really lean and mean on our
shooting day because we we didn't
require any lighting everything was lit
by these gorgeous floor-to-ceiling
windows the the setting was just an
incredible setting I I liked it more
than anything I've ever done because it
was just it was such a small group of
people but all of us were so passionate
about it and we kind of set out to do
the impossible to film the short film in
three hours and we were all excited some
of us haven't gotten any sleep and and
we got there and we just made something
incredible anyway even though it seemed
to be against all odds when I first
heard David's concept of his way of
filmmaking
I wouldn't say was impossible I would
put it as a different approach it was
really new it was so simple it was
ghetto get a film idea get equipment get
location shoot and post-production that
was it but that was just so not so easy
right just saying it that's so easy I
didn't know who's gonna I was I said I
would be saying impossible it was just
different just it was a new unique
approach to filmmaking and if I think
about
future filmmaking I think this is the
best approach for you or independent or
young filmmakers who wouldn't have the
same budget or anything settings are
very very important and for us what was
really important was getting a setting
that very realistically or believably
could be a posthuman ask setting so with
the the posthuman series we're talking
about a future that is actually you know
really utopian on the surface it is
beautiful it is a world of you know
nanomolecular assemblers and what that
means is if you if you're not familiar
with that is it would be like 3d
printers but on steroids so anything
that you could dream up and create in a
digital world could be built for you and
what that would mean in practical terms
was that the posthuman people everybody
would be able to live really in what
today is is considered opulence so we
needed a setting that was believable for
our lead characters to wake up in you
know if you could live in your dream
home what would it look like and it
turned out that there was somebody in
West Vancouver who really had that kind
of home it was a elderly lawyer here in
town who had this gorgeous gorgeous
beach house he actually had a mansion up
on the hill just around the corner that
actually just barely manages to make it
into some of the shots as well but he
was very kind to us he let us have his
beach house but this was there was a big
catch and the first thing was that the
set had been used for other Hollywood
productions before and we weren't even a
Hollywood production when he when I
first approached him he thought we were
but because he was used to having
Hollywood productions there he was used
to cruise of 300 people I mean yeah I
mean even for a Canadian television show
300 people show up because that's the
traditional way of doing these kinds of
things and so he said it'd be twenty
five thousand dollars a day
which he probably thought would scare me
off and it did I
I couldn't have afforded that but
because he was so kind when he answered
my email I thought you know what I'm
gonna write back to him and and so I
wrote back and I said you know it looks
like it's about $1,000 an hour we can be
in and out in three hours so how about
three thousand dollars for three hours
and actually heard back from his
assistants
about a day afterwards and the response
was are you seriously telling us you can
be in and out of the location in three
hours and you know they couldn't believe
it because what they told us in person
when we met them was that you know
productions always get out later than
they're supposed to they always run over
time and there's often you know damage
because there's so many people there but
I told them the crew will be it'll be me
it'll be my wife and I'll be an NYU film
student we're gonna have just three
actors on on set and that's it and we're
not gonna have any lighting and our
equipment would be really small and easy
to set up and yes we can be out in three
hours so being lawyers they were very
clever they wrote a contract that said
that if I was out later than three hours
that it would be an extra thousand
dollar so that was my motivation so it
was like you're looking at a stopwatch
you know while you're filming it was a
rush it was a it was a rush to do that I
mean I can barely remember it I was
literally running between shots at ups
this is the truth we we got about 30
shots I think in the final film there's
you know 18 or 19 shots
oh there was more that we ended up
editing out probably a minute and a half
of film so there were setups that didn't
actually get in so I mean people are
impressed when they watch the proof of
concept and they see that we did it in
three hours but if you saw how much we
actually filmed you'd be even more
impressed and that just comes from
having the right equipment and thinking
about it in a very different way and
because our setting was so picturesque
and perfect it was actually designed by
one of the most famous architects in
Canada his name's Arthur Eriksen
it really did look like the future it
looked like because this lawyer had
really lived very much like people will
be able to in the future I mean he was
able to design this place with Arthur
Erickson and and then they were able to
build it of course it took them years to
do it and you'd be able to do these
things in a very short period of time in
the future but the end results were very
similar and it just brought a level of
believability that's really incredible
and I one of things I love is when I
hear the comment that you know it's
really well lit they did a great job
with the set it's really well lit and
really all we did was just walk in and
set up the cameras yeah it was it was
something the third foundational element
that you need if you're gonna make a
really good film as actors and if I'm
being completely honest I got really
really lucky we got incredible actors so
one of the things I'd recommend is live
in New York live in LA or living in
Vancouver like I do if you live in one
of these film and television capitals
you're gonna live places where there's a
lot of talent and a lot of acting talent
and a lot of undiscovered acting talent
if you really look obviously I couldn't
possibly have afforded or attracted a
you know an a-list Hollywood actor for
this proof of concept but I believed it
was possible to if I if I worked hard
enough and looked hard enough that I
could find actors that had that kind of
talent and presence and amazingly I did
it
we found two actors who were
professional union working actors the
first one was Madison Smith
who plays James Keats he had been in
Supernatural who's recently in legends
of tomorrow he was in Psych he's been in
feature films before that were
independent feature films you know he's
he's a trained actor but he just hadn't
had a lead role yet despite the fact
that he you know obviously looks like a
leading man obviously fits the character
of James Keats extremely well
Madison is he's an amazing actor it was
really cool because we had known each
other before from school I was in the
class after him at the acting school
that we both went to um so I already
knew him I knew that he was still
working and when I was shown the the
image of what James Keats was supposed
to look like according to David I saw
Madison right away and I was like wow
what a perfect casting job um so I was
really excited to work with him and
Madison is so passionate about what he
does he loves acting probably more than
or as much as anyone I know
and he knows everything about movies in
the film industry
and it's so wonderful to work with
somebody who has such a love for the
second time lightning struck was with
Brigitte Graham Brigitte Graham is just
a genius and she is just a wonderful
soul she is she is probably more
impressive for how kind she is and she
is for anything else and that's saying
something because she's she's gorgeous
and she's a very talented actor as far
as I'm concerned she's got the the same
sort of ability as somebody like Olivia
Wilde was someone we were saying a lot
and that's not to take anything away
from Olivia Wilde that's to I just point
out how incredible
Virgen is and how lucky we are that we
got her because to have an actor like
that
on our set who could just nail anything
that we gave her
I mean Brigid nails it on the first take
and then she asks you if you know do you
want that even better and she can do it
which is really really incredible well
uh my co-star her name is Bridget Graham
and she is phenomenal it was actually
quite an amazing experience because I
found out that Bridget was cast and she
was actually showing up to rehearsal day
and I immediately told David that I
actually knew Bridget already we went to
the same acting school a year apart so
it was a it was a great little
experience to find out that hey a person
that I know for some that I I see
working and a person that I'm I'm
excited to see again it's gonna be
working with me on this she is fantastic
as Kathryn we we have won one time in
the in the short film where we we
converse and it's to a point a fight and
and I remember that day in rehearsal was
a was a fun one to do because we had to
make it seem like we not we weren't
angry at each other it was more of a
disappointment which i think is what
real couples do and to have that day of
rehearsal was such an important thing
because we got to play with the levels
of how much are we angry how much we
hurt how much are we sorry how much do
we think that the other person should
forgive us and you can't do that with an
actress who you don't feel comfortable
working with and I 100% so comfortable
working frigid um well my hope is that
it's made into a movie after this and
then several movies um and we can make
movies for maybe a free book in the
series if that's possible because it's
such an incredible such an incredible
book and it's
detailed in such an interesting worlds
that David has created and I when you
read it you see a movie it's just one of
those books where you're like this has
to be a movie and I I think that there's
a huge audience for it even for people
who aren't particularly interested in
sci-fi I think that they'd still love it
so hopefully we can just make as many
movies as possible and show them to as
many people as possible I hope that this
movie gets me I would love to be the
person who brings James Keith's to life
is the avenue for the audience to to
learn about this world but more than
anything I want David's story to be told
because the amount that you'll learn
from the proof of concept is that it's a
cool amazing world that they live in
however if you read past the first 20
pages which is about where we're at
after the proof of concept you get
introduced to such a conflicted world
with so many anti heroes and different
characters bad guys good guys people
that you had no idea existed it's a it's
such a fun amazing book that it's one of
those books that you can't help but see
a movie while you read it so I just I
really want a movie to be made my goals
for posthuman have always been to see it
as a series of films I'd like it to be a
franchise of films I think posthuman is
really important not just as a film
series but because of what it can do for
the world
you know posthuman really depicts a
future that is coming you know unlike
some of the other series that are very
very popular and lucrative they're in
Hollywood from the 60s and 70s but you
know kind of get rebooted posthuman
takes into account the accelerating pace
of information technology and and how
close we already are to having a
superhuman level of machine intelligence
so so strong artificial intelligence and
its really close it'll happen in our
lifetimes and I think we have to be
aware of it but at the same time you
know posthuman is it's a story it's a
narrative and I think one of the best
ways to provoke thought in people is to
is to have a really exciting story
um when I first got involved with this
project I had no idea that I was going
to look as professional as I did because
I've I mean I've done indie movies
before I've done short films before um
but I had no idea that I didn't know
about black magic I didn't know I could
do such incredible things and I had no
idea that David and Jennie he had kind
of hacked the film industry the way it
had and just learned how to do
everything on their own without as much
equipment without as much money without
a big crew so I yeah I would get
involved in more projects that used the
black magic for sure because I had no
idea I always thought I wouldn't get
something that was that could have
quality until I was on set doing
something really professional until I
was doing something Hollywood well one
of the coolest things too is is
posthuman has opened a lot of people's
eyes to the ability to make films with a
low budget with not a huge amount of
crew you have the ability to make these
these movies and the way it's been
looked at a lot is in filmmaking and and
it should be it's a it's a thing that
more filmmakers can make their movies
yeah but the thing that I think doesn't
get talked about is how much of a Avenue
it gives us actors like we yeah if if
posthuman was going to be a movie that
was going to be a major feature film
there's no conversation which my name is
playin there's no talk in which what
about Madison Smith affair yeah for this
movie it's amazing how close we come to
Hollywood standard with such a horrible
equipment just have giant sensor
that could just basically see in the
door again you can just get it you know
with one each it basically just going to
kill me yourself is amazing so acting
like any job you need experience to get
experience and unfortunately the
experience in in low quality short films
isn't what big studios are looking
looking for so if they saw that was in
an indie movie that was filming horribly
even if my performance was okay they
wouldn't take me seriously but was
something like posthuman it gave me and
Madison the opportunity to be in
something that is so professional that's
so beautiful and has a following but we
didn't have to have the big credit that
they usually of course with something
like that so it's it's just the biggest
opportunity is the best thing that I've
ever yeah
digital film technology the affordable
digital film technology and the
incredible camera equipment and the
affordable VFX software are creating a
perfect storm where a new generation of
gamma filmmakers can prove to themselves
that they they can make anything they
want any dream that they have they can
bring it to the screen and in a sense
make it a reality so yeah I mean we're
gonna have a we're gonna have a feature
film I would have to be I'd have to be
dead or incapacitated for us not to have
a feature film we will have a feature
film I guarantee it
I greenlit myself
[Music]